>>> THE JANUARY 6th SELECT
COMMITTEE KICKS OFF THE FIRST OF
SIX PUBLIC HEARINGS A LITTLE
OVER 24 HOURS FROM NOW.
REVEALING THE RESULTS OF ITS
NEARLY YEAR-LONG INVESTIGATION.
LET'S BRING IN CNN'S SPECIAL
CORRESPONDENT, JAMIE GANGEL, AND
CNN'S CHIEF LEGAL ANALYST, YEFRI
TOOBIN.
JAMIE, WHAT ARE YOU LEARNING
ABOUT TOMORROW'S PRIMETIME
HEARING TOMORROW NIGHT, AND
SPECIFICALLY IS THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC GOING TO BE HEARING FROM
SOME OF THE PEOPLE CLOSEST TO
THE THEN-PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> I THINK TOMORROW WE'RE GOING
TO SEE A PROSECUTOR IN EFFECT
LAYING OUT A CASE.
A PREVIEW OF WHAT'S TO COME.
AND WE HAVE BEEN TOLD, WE HAVE
BEEN REPORTING FOR QUITE SOME
TIME, THAT WE'RE GOING TO SEE
NEW VIDEO, NEW TESTIMONY.
THEY INTERVIEWED 1,000 DIFFERENT
WITNESSES.
AND AMONG THOSE WITNESSES,
IVANKA TRUMP.
WHO WAS, LET'S REMEMBER, A
FIRST-HAND WINCE.
SHE WAS AT THE WHITE HOUSE ON
JANUARY 6th.
I THINK THERE WILL BE OTHER
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO HAVE ALSO
GONE IN TO TESTIFY.
MAYBE WE WILL SEE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, THEN ATTORNEY GENERAL
BILL BARR, WHO PLAYED A KEY ROLE
BECAUSE THE COMMITTEE WANTS TO
MAKE THE POINT THAT ON DECEMBER
1st, BILL BARR TOLD DONALD TRUMP
THERE WAS NO SIGNIFICANT
ELECTION FRAUD, AND YET HE KEPT
GOING DOWN THIS PATH.
>> KEPT GOING AND GOING.
SO MUCH OF THE PLOTTING FOR THIS
COUP ATTEMPT, JEFFREY, AS YOU
KNOW, AND AS OUR VIEWERS KNOW,
IT HAPPENED BEHIND THE SCENES.
SO HOW DO THEY BRING THAT
FORWARD DURING THE COURSE OF
THIS PUBLIC HEARING?
>> YOU KNOW, THE FAMOUS
WATERGATE QUESTION WAS WHAT DID
THE PRESIDENT KNOW AND WHEN DID
HE KNOW IT?
I THINK IT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
I THINK THE QUESTION HERE IS
WHAT DID DONALD TRUMP DO?
BECAUSE WHAT WE DON'T KNOW IS
HOW MUCH, IF AT ALL, WAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP INVOLVED IN THE
PLANNING OR KNOWING ABOUT THE
STORMING OF THE CAPITOL?
WHAT ROLE DID HE PLAY IN THE
ATTEMPT TO INTIMIDATE THE VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE?
WHAT ROLE DID HE PLAY IN THE
ATTEMPT TO PUT FORTH FAKE
ELECTORS?
ALL OF THAT, AS YOU SAY, TOOK
PLACE BEHIND THE SCENES.
THE PEOPLE WE NEED TO HEAR FROM
ARE IVANKA TRUMP, WHO WAS THERE,
MARK MEADOWS, WHO WAS THERE, AND
ALSO I THINK VERY IMPORTANTLY,
YESTERDAY THERE WAS A RULING
FROM A FEDERAL JUDGE THAT SAID
SOME OF JOHN EASTMAN'S EMAILS
WERE GOING TO COME OUT.
EASTMAN WAS THE BRAINS OF THE
OPERATION.
HE WAS THE GUY, THE LAW
PROFESSOR WHO WAS GIVING THE
LEGAL ADVICE THAT LED TO THE
EFFORT TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
WHAT DO THOSE EMAILS SHOW?
THAT WILL START TO SHOW WHAT THE
PRESIDENT DID.
>> JAMIE, YOU HAVE BEEN DOING A
LOT OF REPORTING ON WHAT THE
COMMITTEE IS UP TO.
WHO IS THEIR TARGET AUDIENCE?
>> OBVIOUSLY, THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
IT'S BEEN A YEAR AND A HALF.
THEY HAVE TO REMIND PEOPLE.
SOME PEOPLE WANTED TO MOVE ON.
SOME TRUMP SUPPORTERS STILL
BELIEVE THAT IT WAS TOURISTS
THERE.
SO I THINK THE COMMITTEE REALLY
WANTS TO REACH THAT AUDIENCE,
BUT I WOULD SAY THEY HAVE ONE
OTHER AUDIENCE, AND THAT IS AN
AUDIENCE OF ONE, AND THAT'S
ATTORNEY GENERAL MERRICK
GARLAND.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, THE
COMMITTEE IS PRESENTING WHAT
THEY HAVE LEARNED FOR HISTORY,
FOR THE RECORD.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO INDICT
ANYONE, A CRIMINAL REFERRAL, AS
JEFFREY WOULD SAY, REALLY
DOESN'T MEAN ANYTHING.
THE QUESTION IS, IS THERE
EVIDENCE, THEIR TESTIMONY GOING
TO PUSH MERRICK GARLAND AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO TAKE
FURTHER ACTION?
ACCORDING TO MY SOURCES ON THE
COMMITTEE, THEY'RE HOPING IT
WILL.
>> YEAH, I THINK THAT'S THEIR
GOAL RIGHT NOW.
HOW TALL AN ORDER IS IT FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO ACTUALLY CHANGE
MINDS DURING THE COURSE OF THESE
HEARINGS?
>> ONE OF THE THINGS WE LEARNED
ABOUT AMERICAN POLITICS IN THE
TRUMP AND POST-TRUMP ERA IS THAT
THERE ARE NOT A LOT OF OMINDS
OUT THERE TO BE CHANGED.
THIS IS A VERY LOCKED IN
AUDIENCE, AND THERE IS, YOU
KNOW, THERE ARE A HANDFUL OF
PROBABLY SUBURBAN VIEWERS WHO
DON'T FOLLOW POLITICS VERY
CAREFULLY, AND HAVEN'T FOLLOWED
THIS INVESTIGATION CERTAINLY THE
WAY WE HAVE, THAT'S PROBABLY THE
AUDIENCE.
THE FOX NEWS AUDIENCE AND FOX
WILL NOT BE BROADCASTING THE
HEARINGS, THEY'RE NOT THE TARGET
AUDIENCE BECAUSE THEIR MINDS ARE
NOT CHANGED.
BUT THE HANDFUL OF PEOPLE WHO